alors ça les saluts francky donc là je
vous présente francky et où marie ange
porri non mais je le regardais les
petits chiens
mais petit singe savant mariage ce n'est
acquis francky est difficile monsieur
c'est le francky c'est le sait le
docteur bonjour à toi qui es city son
petit lion ça oui ça va bien titiller
francky et dompteur donc au cirque de
l'est et d'un numéro superbe avec six
tigres et de lyon s'est passé magnifique
d'ailleurs ils viendront à bandol le
faire le numéro sur 40 degrés et puis
est bon là il vit un petit peu comme
j'ai bien réussi et que laissera très
bien très bien on voit le vraiment il ya
une dose de professionnalisme et c'est
sa véritable vocation un dompteur aller
les choses un peu plus alors qu'avec que
titi alors quantitié quel âge il ya 16
mois
voilà voilà voilà [ __ ] donc titre
qu'il fallait pas quoi faire mais oui
faut pas qu'elles viennent mais oui bon
alors titi donc à 16 mois il a donc
sauté sur sur sur marie ange et ça se
passe pas très bien mais néanmoins donc
la loi de vous préciser que c'est un
lyon qui n'est pas acquis fait mal là
qui fait mal qui fait très mal à ma
botte c'est un lyon qui n'est pas édenté
qui n'est pas donc mutilés et il n'est
pas du tout et mutilés et c'est pas un
lion qui a été dressé pour faire de la
télévision aux couacs le soir uniquement
uniquement banque est fait pour
travailler en cage et comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure
bon ils sont nés des griffes et les
nôtres ni aidant télécom certains parce
que j'ai horreur de ça ce sont des vrais
fauves que nous faisons travailler
[Musique]